Der Sperd Kerst der Fähr? Ja, der Florentin und Titze, der eine wohlgedient, der andere witzelnd, beide auf dem Flug im Ufo, treiben allesamt den besten Unfug.
Der Komik dienend ist ihre Absicht, mal mehr, mal weniger, mit Taktik, ja der Florentin und Titze, nicht Fleisch, nicht Wurst, vielmehr Gewitztes, Duo seiner Eigenart, das viele Hörer lachen macht. Der galaktisch eigenartige Humor beugt jedem Lippenstillstand bestens vor,
lässt gesichert euch zurück mit einem Lächeln im Gesicht. Humor. Wunderschön, guten Tag, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO mit Stefan. Ja, herzlich willkommen zum Das Podcast UFO Podcast Projekt 2023, nähert sich dem Ende. Nicht zu dieses Projekt hoffe ich, hallo, Florian Newell. Schön, dass ihr da seid und natürlich auch vielen Dank an David Zwo, der uns hier in diese Folge schiesst. Und zwar, ich mag das ja immer ganz gerne, wenn die Intros nochmal einen eigenen Titel haben. Ja. Also das ist nicht nur Intro oder mp3 oder Datei fertig, jetzt abschicken bitte, nochmal Version 3. Unterstrich Final 3. Genau, sondern dieses Intro wurde betitelt mit Reflection on the Water. Natürlich ein toller Gag ist, weil man natürlich einmal die Reflektion, das Nachdenken über Wasser, aber auch die Reflektion, die schimmern auf der Wasseroberfläche. Ganz, ganz toll. Vielen, vielen Dank, David. In G-Moll. In G-Moll. Reflection, wir hören nun, Reflection on Waters, Reflections on Water. Von David Zwei. Von David Zwei. Keine, wenig Künstlernamen in der klassischen Musik, ne, also die alle mit ihrem Eigennamen, mit ihrem persönlichen Klarnamen. Das stimmt nicht, das stimmt nicht. Gibt's Künstlernamen, da gibt's sowas wie Cher. Wer ist der Cher der klassischen Musik, wo man auch mal sagt, ein Künstlernamen so? Ja, nee, Cher jetzt nicht, aber die hießen ja alle nicht so, wie wir sie heutzutage nennen, sondern die haben sich ja alle für den, die haben ja alle sehr viele Vornamen gehabt, Aber zum Beispiel, ich komme jetzt mit dem gleichen Vogel an, aber Richard Wagner hieß ja nicht Richard Wagner, sondern Wilhelm Richard Wagner. Weisst du? Die waren völlig verrückt damals. Ich meine, da ist ja Dua Lipa gar nichts dagegen, dass er sich statt Wilhelm Richard Wagner nennt. Ja, Dua Lipa ist eigentlich Vanessa Dua Lipa. Warum hatten die damals so viele Vornamen? War das einfach so, weil die kriegen alle Namen von den Kindern, die davor gestorben sind oder irgendwie sowas? Ist das so ein Sammelding da? Ja, so ein Sammelbecken an alle, die davor versagt haben oder gestorben sind. Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, einfach viele Opas, Ommas, einfach alle Namen reingeworfen in den Mix und dann schießt ihr da mit 19 Vornamen und einem knallern Nachnamen und dann kannst du dir natürlich als Künstler den besten Vornamen aussuchen.
Ja, ja klar. Das ist ja geil. Es ist immer nur gut, viele Vornamen zu haben, ich weiss das ja, weil dann kannst du immer sagen, welcher ist der beste, welchen benutze ich jetzt immer gerne. Ja, du hättest dich auch für David oder Pascal entscheiden können oder Jean. Technisch gesehen David, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Immer noch.
Das ist ein anderes Thema.
David …
In Erinnerung an David Hasselhoff, der leider verstorben ist. Vielleicht im Laufe der nächsten Woche, in der diese Folge noch mal intensiv geschnitten wird. Und gärt. Und noch mal gären muss, noch mal vor sich hingehen muss. In der Maische liegt. Ihr werdet es hören, wir sind in Hamburg unterwegs. Wir sind in Hamburg, der Perle. Woran hört ihr das das? Ja, in dieser kleinen nördlichen Prise an der Luft. Ja, sicher, da ist eine ganze Luft hier. Ja, das muss man sagen. Wir sind ja aufgetreten, wir haben hier ein bisschen Improv gemacht, deswegen dachten wir uns, okay, wenn Stefan schon mal das Haus verlässt, dann wollen wir ihm auch ein bisschen die Stadt zeigen. Du hast die Stadt erlebt, du hast eingeatmet, eingesaugt. Ich kenne Hamburg, ich mag Hamburg, ich finde Hamburg toll. Du bist ein Stadtschwamm. Ich bin ein Stadtschwamm. Du saugst das in dich auf, du bist in jeder Stadt ein anderer Mensch. Das stimmt wirklich, ich mag Hamburg sehr, es ist natürlich rough, jetzt gerade im Winter, mein Mantel, der Kragen wird hochgestellt, ich stelle mich in den Sturm, der Hut tief ins Gesicht gezogen. Ich stelle mich dir so richtig melancholisch, brütend vor, so am Wasser und
die Gezeiten im Gesicht
und du so, was heisst das eigentlich?
Reflections on the water.
Was ist Wasser eigentlich? Warum ist es
manchmal fest und manchmal Saft?
Eis und
Eis und Wind.
Ich habe tatsächlich letztens einfach mal
gesagt, ich habe die Wäsche aufgehängt
und habe gesagt,
ich weiss nicht, was hier passiert. Ich bin der einzige im Raum, der gerade nicht weiss, was hier los ist. Trocknen, was heisst das, trocknen eigentlich? Warum, was ist los? Weil erstmal war ich sehr dankbar, weil ich mir dachte, es ist nicht selbstverständlich, dass wir in einer Welt leben, wo alles auf ein angenehmes Trockenheitslevel von selbst herunter trocknet. Es könnte sein, und deswegen sind wir wieder, da habe ich nochmal nachgedacht, über das, was du gesagt hast zum Thema Kreationismus und der Schöpfer und Gott und der Allmächtige, dass eigentlich die Welt für den Menschen schon ganz geil ist. Weil wenn du was Kleidung aufhängst, dann musst du nur warten und isst sie genauso, wie du willst. Die wird genauso, wie du willst. Das ist nicht ein bisschen feucht, sondern es ist genauso, wie du willst. Das muss nicht sein. Kannst du aufhören auf den Tisch zu hauen? Entschuldigung. Du hast mir vor, das ist so albern. Du hast mir vorher tausendmal gesagt, ich soll aufhören auf den Tisch zu hauen, weil der Tisch in dem Bild da doof umgeht und du bist die ganze Zeit am rumtrommeln. Ja, sorry. Kein Trommelmann. Wir sind hier auf seismischen Platten, man darf hier nicht zu sehr auf den Tisch hauen, sonst gibt es ein grosses Problem. Nee, ich sag's dir mal gleich, als am Ende der Folge. Du hast recht. Du hast schon recht. Ich würde nur davon ausgehen, wir wären vielleicht andere glibbernde Alien-Menschen mit Schwimmhäuten zwischen den Fingern, wenn die Erde nicht so wäre, wenn die Erde ein bisschen feucht wäre. Ein Leben im Feuchten ist möglich, der Frosch beweist es. Der Frosch beweist es und er geht mit gutem Vorbild voran. Habe ich jetzt allerdings mitbekommen, ich folge ja dem tollen Instagram-Account Frog, der sich mit... R-O-G?
Ja, der sich mit vielen Frosch-Themen beschäftigt und was dort immer gut geklickt wurde, was immer gut ging als Content, was man so, wenn die Redaktion gar keine Ideen mehr hat. Frog got hit by traffic. Ja, auch immer gern genommen, aber auch Frosch sitzt. Ah, aufrecht. Aufrecht. Also nicht so dieses klassische Liegen. Ah, weil die dann dieses Bäuchchen haben. Genau, Bäuchlein ist da. Und diese sehr menschlichen Schenkel. Der zufriedene Blick und die wirklich erschreckend menschlichen Schenkel, wo der Biologe auch nochmal nachguckt. Stammt der Mensch nicht vielleicht vom Froggo ab? Und da kam jetzt allerdings raus, wenn man das macht, ersticken die. Wenn man die aufrecht hinsetzt? Ja. Weil die sehen sehr zufrieden aus. Die sehen sehr zufrieden aus und wirklich in sich ruhend und wirklich gemütlich, aber nein, die haben Todesqualen. Man darf die auf gar keinen Fall aussetzen, weil, und da bin ich auch wieder zu sagen, ist der Mensch nicht ein bisschen krasser als die anderen Tiere, weil der Mensch kann liegen, stehen, Seidelnage, alles drin, der Frosch, Oh, wenn du wenn du gerade nicht auf dem Bauch liegst, tot. Ja, wenn du ein bisschen leichter Winkel tot erstickt. Also, naja, aber gut, Babys ersticken ja auch, wenn sie auf dem Bauch liegen, oder? Wirklich? Kann das nicht passieren? Probier's aus, ich weiss es nicht genau. Ich meine, die ersticken dann auch, aber Babys sind auch sozusagen die schwächste Form des Menschen. Das stimmt, ja. Also sehr, mit grossem Abstand. Obwohl selbst ein Baby einen Frosch besiegen könnte, in den meisten Disziplinen. Babys würde einem Frosch ersticken vielleicht. Das kann sein. Ich meine, er wäre auch der Frosch K.O., aber auch Baby. Ist unentschieden. Ich würde sagen, es ist ein ordentliches Unentschieden. Ja, glaube ich auch. Ein erwachsener Frosch hat gute Chancen gegen ein menschliches Baby. Glaube ich auch. Ne, ich finde es sehr spannend. Ich habe neulich auch einen sehr dollen Streit gehabt mit jemandem übertrocknen. Weil inzwischen checken Leute, ah, Stefan stammte aus einer Heizungsanitätsdynastie ab, Raumklima ist seins, das ist in die Wiege gelegt worden. Ja, da kriegst du die Fragen. Ich habe keine Ahnung davon, ich weiss nichts. Disclaimer, nur Abloh, espaniel. Aber, Leute fragen mich, fragen. So, und dann war grosse Diskussion, Raumentfeuchter. So, jemand wollte sich, jemand in meinem Umfeld, ich nenne keinen Namen, aber ich finde es albern, jemand wollte sich tatsächlich einen Raumentfeuchter kaufen im Winter. Wie arrogant kann man sein. Wie arrogant kann man sein. Also dass man jetzt meint, Gott zu spielen in seinen vier Wänden. Aber was ich noch viel schlimmer finde, ist, Raumentfeuchter ist nicht das, was man will, Feuchtigkeit? Stellen wir nicht alle, wie bescheuert und wie wahnsinnige, kleine Suppenschüsseln mit Wasser auf die Heizung, damit es feuchter wird. Stellen wir uns nicht so kleine Springbrunnen neben das Bett. Soll man nicht, habe ich bei Feng Shui gelernt. Soll man nicht machen. Wasser, weg damit, weg aus dem Schlafzimmer. Andere Geschichte, ich bin in Feng Shui drin. Andere Geschichte.
Du, ich schwitze regelmässig richtig viel, um meinen Raum zu befolgen. So.
Ich versuche wirklich absichtlich, mich zu bewegen, um meinen Raum wirklich feucht zu schwitzen.
Weil wir alle kennen das doofe Gefühl eines trockenen Mundes, trockene Nase morgens zu haben.
Wenn man aufwacht, will man nicht.
Nee. einen Raum wirklich feucht zu schwitzen. Weil wir alle kennen das doofe Gefühl eines trockenen Mundes, trockene Nase morgens zu haben. Wenn man aufwacht, will man nicht. Man will schön feuchte Luft haben. Oder nicht? Ja, die Schleimhäute. Klar, die Schleimhäute. Für die Schleimhäute geil. Absolut. Und ich finde eigentlich das total albern und wider der Natur, plötzlich Raum in Feuchte aufzuhängen. Und ich frage, warum überhaupt diese Diskussion, warum streiten wir uns seit fünfzehn Tagen ohne zu schlafen, weil du diesen Raum in Feuchter holen willst. Und dann hat die Person tatsächlich gesagt, weil die Wäsche sonst nicht trocknet. Okay. So, und dann habe ich natürlich wieder meine Grenzen gestossen, weil du hast mir mal ganz, ganz toll, hast mir mal erklärt, warum Scheiben beschlagen. Ja. Weil warme Luft kann Feuchtigkeit aufnehmen. Mehr Feuchtigkeit als kalte Luft, ja. Genau. Kalte Luft kann so gut wie keine, also je kälter die Luft, desto weniger Feuchtigkeit kann sie aufnehmen. Kalte Luft ist trocken. So, will sie jetzt einen Raumentfeuchter haben, weil die, sie hat, die Wäsche trocknet nicht. So, und ich glaube, ich kann dir genau die Antwort geben, weil ich habe mir nämlich den Wikipedia-Artikel zu Luftfeuchtigkeit durchgelesen, war ein wildes Wochenende. Ich habe mir richtig geschmückt. Ey, ich habe gesagt, du sollst ein bisschen kürzer drehen. Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß, aber ich habe es mir alles gegeben. Wir machen uns alle Sorgen, weil du ein bisschen zu viel Gas gibst. Ich habe es mir alles gegeben. Ich habe wirklich die ersten, den ersten Viertel habe ich komplett durchgelesen. Nein, stimmt. Und man denkt ja, ah, wenn es feucht ist, trocknet die Kleidung nicht. Und ich dachte immer so, weil dann in der Luft kein Platz mehr ist. Genau. Für die Feuchtigkeit von der Kleidung, vom Handtuch, sagen wir mal. Zum Beispiel. Aber das stimmt überhaupt nicht, weil Handtuch, die Wassermoleküle wackeln, weil die eine gewisse Temperatur haben. Warum wackeln sie? Weil die eine Temperatur haben, die wackeln. Das ist wichtig für alles, was jetzt noch passiert. Okay, ich verstehe nicht, warum sie wackeln. Manchmal wackeln die so, dass sie abhauen, dass sie rausgehen und dann sozusagen ihre Flüssigkeitsbindung auflösen und dann als Wasserdampf in die Luft gehen. Weil die wackeln. Und je heisser die sind, desto schneller wackeln die, desto höher ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass dieser Zustand entsteht und dass die dann übergehen in Dampf. Sollte man dann den Raum nicht einfach heizen? Das ist gut, aber jetzt ist nämlich die Frage, das hat ja überhaupt nichts mit Luftfeuchtigkeit zu tun, weil ob die jetzt in die Luft fliegen oder nicht, hat ja nichts damit zu tun, wie die Luft aussieht. Aber jetzt kommt's. Das Gleiche passiert auch von Luft zu Handtuch. Oh Gott! Das heisst, auch in der Luft sind Wassermoleküle, die wackeln auch, und wenn die auf das Handtuch treffen, dann gehen wir wieder zurück in Wasser. Das heisst, was letzten Endes passiert ist nur... Im Handtuch ist nicht mein Waschmaschinenwasser, sondern im Handtuch ist fucking die Luftwolle aus dem Raum. Da ist auch nur Wasser drin, ja sicher. Das heisst, es geht eigentlich nur um die Netto-Trocknung, wie viele Moleküle in die Luft gehen und wie viele von der Luft aufs Handtuch gehen. Das heisst, wenn jetzt die Luftfeuchtigkeit hoch ist, gehen mehr von der Luft aufs Handtuch, das heisst, die Netto-Verlust an Wassermolekülen im Handtuch ist kleiner, aber es gehen erst mal genauso viel weg, es kommen dann nur noch mehr rein.
Du willst doch komplett kalte, weil ich verstehe diesen Satz auch nicht, ich habe im Winter so grosse Probleme, meine Wäsche trocken zu bekommen.
Das ist ein Satz?
Der fiel, in diesem Streit, in diesem ellenlangen Streikgespräch.
An den du dich sehr gut erinnern kannst. Du musst sehr investiert gewesen sein in diesen Streit.
Im Winter kriege ich meine Wäsche nicht trocken, Stefan, Stefan, Stefan, hör mir doch mal zu, hör auf zu schreien, warum weinst du schon wieder, du nimmst das alles ein bisschen zu ernst, bitte, bitte, bitte lass mich doch diesen Raumentfeuchter kaufen. Ich habe nur gedacht, warum im Winter, warum trocknet die im Winter, weil du hast ja, okay. Weil es kalt ist, das stimmt schon. Nee, aber wenn es kalt ist, ist die Luft trockener. Ja, also sie kann weniger Feuchtigkeit aufnehmen. Wie feucht sie tatsächlich ist, ist eine andere Frage. Kalte Luft ist ein kleiner Eimer, warme Luft ist ein grosser Eimer. Aber wie viel Wasser im Eimer ist, ist nochmal ein ganz anderes Thema. Aber in die kalte Luft passt weniger. Ganz kleiner Eimer. Wenn du einen kleinen Eimer hast, musst du ja nicht nur notwendigerweise leer oder voll sein. Ich bin nicht besch... Du musst nicht mit mir reden, jetzt wäre ich drei. Das ist ja dann die Möglichkeit. Ja, ich glaube, es ist Unfug. Also je kälter die Luft, also je mehr Winter ist, um das mal kurz zu vereinfachen, desto einfacher müsste die Wäsche trocken. Oder man sagt … Ja, weil es ist kälter. Aber es gibt dann noch, und das ist ja das Geile, dass es immer so Cheatcodes gibt in der Natur,
dass wenn es ganz kalt ist, dann gibt es diese Eisfrosttrocknung.
So wurde es dann so mit so Schneedampf, so nochmal ganz neue Aggregatszustellen.
Stannend sind Wikipedia-Artikel mit diesen Geräuschen.
Wo du das nur so einmal raushängst in die Kälte und dann so … Mit diesen Geräuschen.
Wo du das nur so einmal raushängst in die Kälte und so.
Und dann geht es so raus und dann geht es ganz schnell.
Warum das passiert, weiss ich noch nicht.
Ich habe nur den ersten Teil von der Wikipedia gelesen.
Okay, ja, ich, ja, gut.
Also wo ich schon verstehe, keine Ahnung, kalte Luft kann das nicht so gut aufnehmen und dann trocknet es vielleicht nicht. Und kalte Luft, also Wärme hilft natürlich auch. I don't know, es ist ein schwieriges Thema. Ich verstehe Raumentfeuchter nicht, ich denke, es ist albern, es ist ein Riesengerät, das stelle ich mir vor. Ich habe nie gefragt, wie gross es wirklich ist. Ich stelle mir vor, es ist so ein grosses, ein Meter hoher Obelisk. Es ist ein grosser Obelisk, den ich auch mal hatte, weil, jetzt wirst du mich vernarren, und zwar, ich habe ja im Keller gewohnt, lange Zeit, und da ist bei einem Jahrhundert Regen, ist auch Wasser in den Keller gelaufen, weswegen der komplette Teppichboden nass war, auch unter die Regale nass, alles nass, während ich Battlefield gespielt habe, kamen die Wasserschwallen rein. War dir egal. Im Battlefield war trocken. Genau, da waren wir in der Wüste, ist ja kein Problem. Und in Battlefield bin ich selbstbewusst. Das stimmt, ja. In Battlefield bin ich Teamleader. Da sage ich immer, go guys, bravo, hit point, let's go, man down, yes, engage guy. Da bin ich immer dabei. Nice, spannend. Und zurück kommt immer nur, weil irgendjemand sein Mikrofon offen hat. Und das war meine Jugend. Quasi so habe ich Leute im Internet kennengelernt. Und da hieß es irgendwann, oh, wie kriegen wir jetzt das Wasser, das im Teppich unterm Regal ist. Also das ist so, das ist im Keller des Regals, könnte man sagen. Und dann dachten wir, okay, wenn jetzt die Luft einfach ganz trocken ist, dann kann das gut trocknen. Also hatte ich auch einen Luftentfeuchter. Das Geile ist ja, der Luftentfeuchter saugt Wasser aus der Luft. Das ist ein ganz merkwürdiges System, weil du hast am Ende, du hast den da einfach im Raum stehen, still, einfach awkward silence die ganze Zeit. Macht der nichts, hat der kein Geräusch? Nee, ich dachte auch, ich stalle den an so und du machst den an und es ist nichts. Und der steht einfach nur da und du denkst dir so, kann ich dir ein Glas Wasser anbieten? Ja genau, wie so ein Handwerker in einer Wohnung, man weiss nicht, wie man damit umgehen soll. Das ist einfach nicht. Entschuldigung. Kann ich Ihnen irgendwas ... Hi, hi, hallo, Stefan, der dich gerade aufgebaut hat, genau, hi, Arbeitest du schon oder kann man irgendwie helfen oder muss ich dich anschalten? Gibt's jemanden Einschalten? Nee, okay. Mal einmal um, auf umlegen, auf die Seite legen. Okay, scheint nichts zu verändern. Ich höre immer noch kein, ich höre ein leichtes Geräusch vielleicht. Ah nee, es ist der PC, der läuft. Okay, gut, ich schätze, ich mach's. Und Und dann guckst du mal rein und es ist Wasser drin. Ja, das ist so geil. Da ist Wasser drin, das aus der Luft geholt wird. Und es ist wirklich, beim ersten Mal dachte ich mir, nee, das ist jetzt Quatsch. Oder hat jemand irgendwie Wasser reingefüllt, das war schon von Anfang an dabei oder so. Aber der saugt das Wasser aus der Luft und es ist richtig abgefahren, weil du dir denkst, okay, da ist ständig auch Wasser immer in der Luft. Kann man das denn gut trinken? Das darf man auf gar keinen Fall trinken, weil das ist ja irgendwie so destilliertes Wasser dann, das ja dann irgendwie aus irgendeinem Grund dich umbringt. Also sehr reines Wasser bringt dich um. Das ist sehr reines Wasser, weil das saugt irgendwie Salze irgendwo raus. Keine Ahnung. Und deswegen darf man das auf gar keinen Fall trinken. Und es ist aber eine coole Möglichkeit, auch einfach Wasser zu gener generieren. Ich dachte ihm immer so, ich bin im Dschungel oder in der Wüste und habe einfach diesen Larry hier auf dem Rücken. Und der saugt immer schön Wasser raus. Aber anscheinend wird das nicht gemacht, anscheinend ist das keine gute Idee, weil es sehr viel Strom braucht und man einfach stattdessen lieber eine Flasche Wasser mitnehmen kann. Aber nur als Idee für mich in meinem Kinderkopf war es so, ja, ich bin auf meinem Kamel und gehe durch die Wüste und dann … Dein Kamel. Ja, weil ich wollte immer so einen stillen Begleiterfreund. Nee, es klingt so, als suchst du das Tier, was das perfektioniert hat mit dem Wasser am Rücken. Ja, das stimmt. Aber man kann nicht vom Kamel trinken, oder? Nee, nee, bisschen nicht. Es ist nicht so eine … Wie Kokosnuss. Machst du ein Loch rein und dann … Oh! Aber es ist nicht so eine ... Wie heissen die nochmal hier in diesem Star Wars diese Elche, diese Yeti-Elche? Banta, Yanta? Wampas. Wampas, auf denen man reiten kann, wo Han Solo sich reinlegt. Ja. Genau, Wampa? Ja. Oder Kämpft Luke gegen den Wampa. Der Kämpft gegen W Wampo. Banter. Banter sind diese braunen Mammutmässige. Genau, meine ich auch. Was suchst du? Den, wo Hans Hörter sich reinlegt. Mit dem lustigen Namen. Jarlak. Nee. Sordog. Ach Gott, wie hieß das? Ich habe alles vergessen. Stefan Tietze muss recherchieren. Stefan Tietze hat keine Credibility. Ich hab überhaupt gar nicht mehr, ich weiß, alles vergessen. Stefan Tietze ist kein echter Star Wars-Fan, ja, er hat schon wieder alles vergessen. Ich habe keine Verbindung zum Internet, es könnte ein großes Problem geben. Ja, er ist kein Jedi im Meister sein, Lichtschwert ist blau, ja, er kennt sich nicht mehr aus. Town Town. Town Town, so, da waren wir gar nicht nah dran. So, aber haben Kamele auch eine potenzielle Town Town-Situation, wenn du wirklich in der Wüste bist und du verdurstest. Und dann denkst du noch mal nach, ich habe ja einen Kamel und da heisst es Wasser in den Höckern. Wasser in den Höckern. Und dann kommt noch so eine ganz schwammrige Erinnerung an den Kamelhänder, der sagt, Wasser in den Höckern, Wasser in den Höckern. Obi-Wan, was sagst du mir? Wasser in den Höckern. Okay. Und dann packst … und dann … also, erstmal natürlich unangenehme Situation mit dem Kamel selbst. Ja. Und kannst du dann ein Kamel, die Höcker aufschneiden und das trinken? Klar. Oder speichern die das in so Gefässen und es ist so, du musst dann so wie so eine Lunge ausquetschen. Es ist wie so eine Wasserlunge. Wie so ein Granatapfel irgendwie so.
Boah, es ist widerlich.
Es ist ja, there's no way, dass wenn man den Höcker abschneidet, da nur fucking Wasser drin ist. Das ist halt wie so ein Brunnen, so ein Schulbrunnen, wo du auch so einen Knopf drückst und dann spritzt du raus.
Weil ich meine, es gab hundertprozentig diese Situation schon, wo jemand kurz vor einem Verdursten mit einem Kamel in der Wüste unterwegs war und dann überlegt hat, ist es jetzt, probiere ich es jetzt, mache ich jetzt das Towntown-Manöver oder ist es eine richtig dumme Idee und ich bringe meinen Kamel um für nichts? Entschuldigung. Entschuldigung. Ich habe gerade mal Kamelhöcker innen gegoogelt und finde nichts. Weil du kein Internet hast. Aber wenn die leer sind, liegen die auf der Seite, das wusste ich auch nicht. Ja, die sind schlapp. Dann liegen die so auf der Seite und dann haben die so zwei Lappen umgekippt. Das ist schon faszinierend, oder? Ja, ja. Aber ich weiss nicht, das ist bestimmt so eine Situation, wo, keine Ahnung, wenn du mit dem Autostrandest, kannst du irgendwie das Scheibenwischerwasser trinken oder irgendwie sowas. Da weisst du dann, wo du den Strohhalm reinstecken musst oder zu Not trinkst du das Öl oder sowas.
Zu Not ist Öl.
Zu Not ist Öl. Erstmal Scheibenwischerwasser und dann zu Not Öl.
Dann Öl, dann Benzin in der Reihenfolge.
Dann Benzin und dann die werden die Reifen gegessen.
Und dann guck dann im Handschuh vor, ob da nicht noch eine Flasche Wasser liegt. Nee, das geht gar keine Frage. Ich glaube, Scheibenwischwasser ist nicht so gut. Ja, aber bevor du verdurstest, bevor du wirklich sagst, drei, zwei, eins, ich weiß nicht, ich hatte... Ich weiß auch nicht. Ich hatte noch nie... Wann hattest du am meisten Durst in deinem Leben? Oh, gute Frage. Gab es eine Situation, wo du wirklich dachtest, so viel Durst hatte ich noch nie, ich bin so durstig. Ich glaube, es gab den ersten Podcast-Ufo-Auftritt, da hatten wir noch kein Wasser auf der Bühne, weil wir dachten, was ... Es ist ein lames Element, es ist das dümmste Element. Ich habe vorher gesagt, ich will Feuer auf der Bühne, warum kriegen wir nur Wasser? Da waren wir auch so arrogant, so haben wir mit unserem Staff gesprochen. Warum haben wir keine Erde, selbst Erde ist cooler. Nein, entweder wir haben alle vier Elemente auf der Bühne oder keins, aber wir haben nicht nur eins. Stefan und Flont sind wieder super anstrengend heute, oder? Ach Gott, dieser Podcaster. Ach Gott, naja. Ja gut, dann kommen, dann machen wir die Wasserflaschen von der Bühne. Hatten wir nichts auf der Bühne und ich merke ab Minute eins, wie mein Mund sich so nach Wasser lächzt. Und alle Zungenpartikel waren so, Hilfe, ich bin seit fünf Tagen ohne Wasser in der Westsahara unterwegs.
Speichel, wo ist Speichel?
Speichel, er hat uns schon verlassen.
Wo kommt er?
Wenn er noch einen Satz spricht, zieht sich ja alles zusammen.
Oh nein, oh nein, Florin, ich habe aufgehört zu sprechen.
Oh nein, wir müssen die Lücke füllen.
Die Leute gucken schon, sie schauen mich an.
Oh nein, haben wir noch irgendwas? Welches Wort braucht am wenigsten Flüssigkeit? Salz. Salz. Aber kann man, könnte man jetzt heute diese Aufnahme nochmal anhören und würde man das merken oder hast du das meistens verständlich? Naja, man merkt es daran. Also wenn man den Mund, es gibt, man hört, wenn der Mund zu trocken oder zu feucht ist. Gerade fast ein bisschen zu trocken, aber eher tendenziell gute Feuchtigkeit.
Stefan Tietzer aus Dortmund wettet, dass er nur am Schmatzgeräusch von Dua Lipa erkennen kann, ob ihr Mund zu trocken oder zu feucht ist.
Kannst du ein bisschen näher kommen, Dua?
Kannst du ein bisschen näher kommen?
Kannst du ein bisschen näher kommen? Kannst du ein bisschen näher kommen?
Nee, du kommst ein bisschen näher mein Ohrchen.
Kannst du ein bisschen näher zu meinem Ohrchen?
Okay, geil, jetzt können wir es versuchen.
Alles klar, wir können es versuchen.
Nee, du Schätzchen, du musst noch ein bisschen näher kommen zu meinem Ohr.
Schmerz mich so richtig ins Ohr.
No, darling, you need to get at it with Klaus.
Kann ich es noch mal hören?
Das ist perfekt.
Absolut perfekt.
Ich bräuchte jetzt die Antwort, zu trocken oder zu feucht?
Ach so, zu feucht, wenn man.
Richtig, yay, stark.
Oh Gott, creepy Wette.
Richtig unangenehme Wette.
Unangenehme Wette, für alle beteiligt.
Für alle beteiligt, vor allem, was ich mir bei Wetten, dass Wetten immer vorstelle, ist, der Typ hat das ja trainiert.
Wer?
Hunderte, Thomas Gottschalk. Der hat ja zu Hause schon hunderte Wetten wegmoderiert, um zu üben. Und dann stelle ich mir mal vor, wie diese Person einfach hunderte Mal übt und irgendwie ständig Leute aus der Umgebung ihn anschmatzen müssen und sowas. Und der einfach, glaube ich, nicht so beliebt ist. Der ist zwar jetzt im Fernsehen und ist cool und so, aber er ist eigentlich so ein bisschen der Kurzarmige, der Narr, der so vorgeführt wird. Wie empathisch warst du als Kind? Also wie enttäuscht warst du für die Leute, die gewettet haben, also Wetten eingebracht haben in die Sendung und der Schriftzug fiel herunter, weil die Wette nicht geklappt hat? Ja. Wie traurig warst du für die Leute? Warst du there for the drama und wolltest es gerne sehen, dass sie alle versagen oder?
Bei mir war es immer so, sobald einer versagt, will ich, dass alle anderen auch versagen.
Damit alle gleich geht.
Genau, ich will nicht, also die absolute worst case für mich war eine Sendung, wo alle gewinnen und nur einer es nicht schafft.
Ich will immer, wenn einer es nicht schafft, sage ich, okay, ab jetzt will ich, dass jeder versagt. Bis zu dem Punkt wollte ich, dass alles schaffen. Das war immer meine... Aber du musst dir ja vorstellen, dass wenn alle verlieren, die Show nicht funktioniert. Gab es das mal in der Sendung? Wir hatten das, wo wirklich alle verloren haben und es keinen Wettkönig gab. Nee, Wettkönig war ja nicht, wer gewonnen hat, sondern wer, oder? Ja, aber der Zuschauer kann natürlich auch verweigern und sagen, nee, die sind alle Trottel. Hat mal jemand gewonnen, der? Konnten Leute gewinnen, die nicht gewonnen haben, die hatte? Oh, das ist eine gute Frage, das weiß ich gar nicht. Das weiß ich gar nicht. Da müssen wir nochmal in die Wetten, dass Archive schauen. Lass uns am Wochenende einfach nochmal alle Folgen Wetten, dass nochmal komplett durchgucken. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum wir darüber reden. Ich mochte das gar nicht. Ich mochte das auch nicht, dass es wieder war. Ich hab das nicht gesehen. Ich hab's auch nicht gesehen, ich fand's doof, dass es wieder Thema war. Ich finde, das ist ein rückwärtsgewandte Scheiße. Rückwärtssalto. Ja, wir machen ein Rückwärtssalto. Ich meine, what the fuck, kriegen wir ein erstmal, klar ist lineares Fernsehen tot, ich verstehe auch, dass man alle wieder Bock haben, irgendwie so lagerfeuermäßig davorzuszen und alle irgendwie bei Threads jetzt schreiben. Das finde ich alles cool. Können wir nicht was Neues machen? Warum muss wieder Thomas Gottschalk mit so einem Ouija-Brett zum Leben erweckt werden, um dann nach seinem... Aus der Gruft in Kalifornien, wo er im Keller liegt. Wo er schon lange tot ist. Oh Gott! Und Und das hat die Erf-Redakteure dann schnell ihr Ritualbuch zusammenklappen und diese so prickelnde, brodelnde, grüne Kesselchen haben. Wo drei Praktikanten geopfert wurden für Blutopfer, um ihn wieder zu beleben. Exakt, so und dann wird er in der ganzen Sendung mit Babyblut am Leben erhalten. Ja, ja. So, I don't know, also muss das sein. Deswegen, ich sag ihr immer, ich showidee pizzaturm okay ganz simpel pizzaturm pizzaturm so wir alle essen pfschmitz wir alle essen pizza so ralf schmitz kommt auf die bühne sagt herzlich willkommen zu pizzaturm schön dass sie da sind wir haben heute wieder tolle promi-gäste mit dabei du erlieber ist mit dabei emma stone mit dabei, Lena Meyer-Landroth ist mit dabei und Cher ist mit dabei. Bravo, bravo, bravo. So, und dann gibt es vier Pizzatürme, also zehn Pizzakartons übereinander. Aber man weiss, und es ist eine Pizza in einem der Pizzakartons, aber man weiss nicht, in welchem Pizzakarton, okay?
Du hast zehn Pizzakartons übereinander, in einem ist eine Pizza. Und jetzt müssen die Promis diesen ganzen Pizzakartonturm hochheben und dann gucken, ob sie rausfinden, in welchem der Kartons die Pizza drin ist. Das ist aber eher, der Name klingt fast spannend, weil ich dachte, okay, wir bauen einen riesen Pizzaturm und am Ende muss Dua Lipa, ähm, können wir auch noch machen, am Ende können wir, oh, am Ende, das finde ich auch geil, das finde ich gut, und dann, weil es gibt ja nicht nur Treffer oder Nicht-Treffer, sondern man kann ja auch, also wenn jetzt Dua Lipa sagt, ähm, ich glaube in Pizzakarton Nummer acht. Ich glaube es ist in Pizzakarton Nummer acht.
Okay, machen wir auf und dann macht man als erstes die acht auf.
Acht auf und alle acht, acht, acht, acht, acht im Publikum acht auf, leer, dann wird sieben aufgemacht, leer, Werbung, dann wird neun aufgemacht, leer, dann wird neun aufgemacht, leer, dann wird sieben aufgemacht, leer, Werbung, dann wird neun aufgemacht, leer, dann wird sechs aufgemacht, da ist drei drin, drin, und das heisst, sie war zwei entfernt. Ich hasse es. Sie war zwei entfernt. Lass uns Deal or No Deal spielen, Deal or No Deal, mit ganz vielen Koffern, in jedem ist eine unterschiedliche Anzahl von Pizza, in einem ist nur ein Slice, in einem Koffer sind zwei Slice. Und man muss am Gewicht des Koffers herausfinden. Und ich sag, nee, und man dealt halt. Und ich sag, und du bist dieser Dealer, der immer sehr interessiert ist an dem Pizzakarton. Also, ich wähle am Anfang aus die sechs. Dann kriege ich die sechs hingestellt. Ich darf nicht das Gewicht sehen. Und dann, ja. Aber jetzt wird die gereicht. Genau. Aber kannst du nicht an der... Dann kann ich fünf Pizzastücke auswählen, Pizzakarton, dann habe ich die 18. Und dann wird die 18 geöffnet und ich sehe, es ist ein Stück drin. Okay, ist gut. Ein Stück drin. Ja. Das heisst, der Rest der Pizza ist noch in allen anderen Kartons oder in meinem. Kann auch sein, dass alle leer sind und in meinem ist alles bis auf ein Stück. Aber was machen die Promis? Die stehen da oben die ganze Zeit, die ganzen neun Stunden, stehen sie da oben und halten die Pizzakartons, bis ich sage, die vier.
Glaubst du, man kriegt im Management von Duoliba das durchgebracht, dass Duoliba neun Stunden lang stehen und einen Pizzakarton geht?
Das ist eine Frage des Geldes und der Menge der Pizza.
Nur um auf meine Idee zurückzukommen, Pizzaturm, das Tolle ist ja, dass am Ende kriegt jeder Promi die Pizza sowieso, weil dann müssen ja eh alle Kartons aufgemacht werden und am Ende hat jeder Promi eine Pizza und man isst zusammen Pizza. Und dann kann man währenddessen nochmal drüber reden, ah ja, du dachtest in der acht, aber es war eigentlich in der sechs. Wir reden nochmal drüber? Ja, und dann sagt Emma Stone, oh, ich lag ja völlig daneben, ich dachte es ist die zwei, aber es war am Ende die sechste.
Das wussten wir alle schon, warum reden Sie wieder darüber?
Weil Sie nochmal ihre Erfahrungen und ihr Erlebnis, aber Sie können nochmal erklären, warum Sie sich so entschieden haben. Das erklären Sie ja wahrscheinlich davor auch schon. Ja, aber mir geht es einfach darum, dass du am Ende nochmal so einen Moment hast, wo alle nochmal zusammensitzen, eine Pizza essen, vielleicht kriege ich das Publikum auch eine Pizza. Jeder kriegt ein Stück oder so. Und dann im Anschluss läuft dann die gleiche Show nochmal mit so einem Reaction-Video von Knossi oder so. Genau, ja, einfach direkt hinterher. Wo er auch nochmal seine Erfahrungen. ZDF. Er sagt, sie wollte erst die acht nehmen, hat sich dann für sechs entschieden. Ich hätte ja die sieben genommen, wäre es aber auch nicht gewesen. Aber ehrlich gesagt, so furchtbar, furchtbar, furchtbar scheusslich und schrecklich ich diese Idee finde. Also konstruktives Feedback ist halt auch was, was mir helfen würde, die Idee weiterzuentwickeln. Ich finde es scheisse, scheisse, scheisse. Kacke, kacke, kacke. Ich finde nichts daran gut. Aber trotzdem finde ich es immer noch besser, als wir hätten das wieder laufen zu lassen. Also ich sag mal so, falls Ralf Schmitz keinen Bock hat, das zu moderieren, ich würde mich anbieten. Und ich glaube, es ist nicht so leicht. Probiert das gerne mal zu Hause aus, Hashtag Pizzaturm. Ich glaube, du könntest so gut eine Samstagabendshow moderieren. Warum verfolgst du diesen Traum nicht? Weil ich faul bin. Ist das noch ein Traum von dir? Nee, also, es war einfach so faul. Es ist so... Ja, aber es ist doch auch... Du kriegst auch Texte geschrieben und so. Ich meine, worauf bist du jetzt zu faul für?
Ich will nicht so früh aufstehen.
Das ist abends die Show.
Ich will auch nicht, dass mir Leute sagen, was ich anziehen soll und was ich machen soll.
Ich will einfach nur ...
Deswegen mag ich Podcasts, Streaming, Improv.
Niemand sagt dir, was du machen sollst.
Du bist einfach da.
Außer die ganzen Regelbücher.
Du hast die Kleidung an, die du tragen willst.
Und es ist alles in Ordnung. Ich will mich nicht mehr verkleiden, Stefan. Ich will nicht mehr irgendein Kostüm tragen, sondern ich finde es super, du willst dich nicht verstellen. Es braucht nur Leute wie dich im Samstagabend Fernsehen, finde ich. Ich finde ja per Liederschein schön. Ja, weil ich glaube, es ist nicht so leicht, weil ja klar, je höher die Pizza ist, denkst du jetzt, das kannst du halt gucken, weil du kannst den Turm so ein bisschen wackeln. Ich hasse das. Ich finde es so scheusslich. Aber ich würde es trotzdem lieber gucken, als hätten das. Ich habe zumindest eine Idee gehabt. Ja ne, meine Idee wäre folgendes, also, das ganze Publikum legt einen Zehner in die Mitte. Okay. So, das ist ein grosser, das sind so sehr viele Leute, das ist eine Messehalle. Es kommt sehr viel Geld zusammen. Es sind viele Zehner, aber darf man auch einen Zwanziger hinlegen und dann einen Zehner rausnehmen oder müssen es Zehnerscheine sein? Ist es Teil der Show? Oder darf man auch zwei Fünfe rein? Was ist mit Kleingeld? Du kannst so viel Geld reinlegen, wie du willst. Ah, okay. Mindestens zehn Euro. Okay. So, und du hast halt eine Messehalle, wie so eine Wetten-Das-Show, wo so eine Messe-Das-Show mal stattgefunden hat, mit so richtig sehr viel Publikum, so 2000 Leute. Die geben alle Zehner, Zwanziger, vielleicht hast du reiche Leute, die irgendwie auch mal ein Hunderter reinwerfen oder Tausi. So, und dann legen wir das ganze Geld in die Mitte. Und dann gucken, also können Leute anrufen, Prominente können anrufen, wenn sie bereit sind für, dann sagen sie ihren Preis und dann können sie in die Show kommen. Also Prominente können sich einkaufen, nee, nicht nur Prominente, alle können sich einkaufen in die, nee, pass auf, also, Amateurbands zum Beispiel, also wenn man jetzt seine Band promoten will, kann man anrufen, in der Show anrufen und sagt, okay, weiss nicht, wir zahlen irgendwie 2000 Euro, legen wir auf den Haufen auch drauf und dann können wir in die Sendung, kriegen wir je nach, was gerade so der Minutenpreis ist, was sich an diesem Haufen ermisst, der da ist.
Moment, aber dann sagt der Moderator, okay, 2000 Euro passt und dann steigen die jetzt ins Auto und müssen erst noch ins Studio fahren und Soundcheck und alles. In dem Fall bist du irgendwie in der Gegend.
Pass auf, also das ist die Budgetshow.
Das Publikum bietet den Grundstock, den Pot.
Ja.
Daraus errechnet sich der Minutenpreis. Das ist unser Budget für die ganze Sendung. Die Sendung geht, sagen wir mal, zwei Stunden, okay? Wir haben zwei Millionen Euro auf diesem Ding. So, dann kannst du dir ausrechnen, was der Minutenpreis ist. Und anhand alles dessen Geld, was in die Mitte gelegt wurde, errechnet sich das. So, das ist der Preis. Okay, es gibt dann auch keine Werbung, sondern die Sendung wird alleine durch dieses Publikum finanziert. Das Publikum finanziert, das ist eine crowdgefunderte, aber Mikrokosmos crowdgefunderte Sendung. Das ist der Minutenpreis. So, okay, dann bring bring, hallo, hier ist Dirk Nowitzki. Genau, Dirk Nowitzki, so, Promi-Gäste wiederum will die Sendung ja haben. Genau. Die Sendung, da sind nur fünf Holzstühle auf der Bühne, nicht die Bühne ist radikal leer, es sind zwei Kameras, Holzstühle, das Riesenpublikum und der Haufen Geld. Und die Idee ist, dass das Publikum gemeinsam versucht mit dem Moderator, die möglichst coole Show zu machen. Das Budget liegt die ganze Zeit da, alle sehen's. Jetzt die Frage, ihr versucht dann,
Prominente zu bekommen in der Sendung. Dirk Nowitzki sieht die Sendung und sagt, ich wäre dabei, mein Preis wäre zum Beispiel dreitausend Euro. Also dann ruf, okay, bring bring, hallo, hier ist Dirk Nowitzki. Okay, hättest du Bock mit der Sendung zu sein, was ist dein Preis? Ja, ich hätte gern fünftausend Euro. Okay, alles klar, dann musst du mit dem Publikum, kannst du dann als Moderator entscheiden, ah wie geil, für 5000 Euro ist das das wert? Publikum ruft, ja das ist uns wert, rufen sie alle gleichzeitig. Dann, Dirk Nowitzki, komm mit der Bahn schnell an. Ok, also dann, ich steige jetzt in die Bahn, so in 40 Minuten bin ich da. Ja super, alles klar. Alles klar, dann ziehe ich mir jetzt die Schule an. So, super. Ok, bis gleich. Wir schreiben auf, du als Moderator, ah in 40 Minuten Dirk Nowitzki ist da. Geil, Highlight. Countdown? Nee, nicht unbedingt. Vielleicht. Und du bist nicht aufgeschrieben auf dem Whiteboard. Ja, genau. Das müsst ihr euch aber kaufen, das Whiteboard müsst ihr euch kaufen von dem Geld. Ach so. Verstehst du nicht, wie es läuft? Wir haben so einen Requisitenkatalog, wo wir aussuchen können, welche Requisiten wollen wir uns kaufen. Wollen wir einen Scheinwerfer, wollen wir einen roten Scheinwerfer haben, falls, wenn Dirk reinkommt, wäre cool. So, angenommen jetzt sagt nämlich die Band, was ist das eine Band, Tokio Hotel sagt, okay, wir kommen vorbei, wir würden aber 2000 Euro kosten für einen Auftritt, dann sorgt gefälligst dafür, dass bis sie kommen, ihr einen coolen Auftritt für die machen könnt, Konfetti-Kanone. sagt, okay, wir sagen, machen wir tausend Euro, dafür wollen wir eine coolen, eine Disco-Kugel haben. Genau, okay, und du sagst, okay, die kostet hier in diesem Katalog 20 Euro. Es ist easy. Das Ding ist aber, ihr könnt diesen Budgettop wieder auffüllen, wenn ihr Leute einladen, die nicht bekannt sind, die aber Sendezeit sicher kaufen. Ah, okay. Oder Werbung. Melitta ruft an und sagt, wir würden gerne Werbung schalten in eurer Sendung. Hier, der Spot kommt an den USB-Stick, bringt den Kurier, euch den vorbei, in den guten 1 Stunde 20 habt ihr diesen USB-Stick dabei, kriegt ihr den in der Zeit, dafür kriegt ihr 20.000 Euro. Okay, es ist quasi so Redaktionssitzung die Sendung. Die Sendung wird in der Sendung geplant. Nicht geplant. Und am Ende, kurz fünf Minuten vor Ende, kommt Dirk Nowitzki und Bill Kauditz noch mal rein und sagt, hey. Also angenommen, Dirk Nowitzki ist jetzt da, ist in der Sendung, was macht er dann? Du kannst ihn interviewen. Interviewen, okay. Du kannst vorher Redakteure mit dem Geld einkaufen, die sich gute Fragen überlegen für dich und den Auftritt gut vorbereiten. Du kannst dir auch ein Kostüm leisten von dem Budgetgeld. Es ist nur sozusagen Budget die Sendung. Und alle sehen im Publikum, wie schwer ist es eigentlich, eine Sendung zu machen. Aber mir gefällt dieser Improv, alles entsteht im Moment, yes and Moment. Man muss ewig warten, bis was passiert. Nein. Und der Moderator sagt dann, hey Leute, Dua Lipa hat angerufen, sie würde zwei Millionen verlangen, wir haben jetzt leider nur zehntausend auf dem Haufen. Wenn jeder noch so ungefähr vierzigtausend Euro reinlegen würde, könnten wir heute Abend Dua Lipa sehen, wie ihr wollt. Ja, oder. Also man muss ständig um Geld betteln eigentlich. Ja, aber ist nicht Fernsehen ein ständiges um Geld betteln? Eigentlich nicht, wir sehen einen Bagger, der irgendwie einen Goldfisch aus dem Aquarium holt. Wir sehen es nicht, sehr richtig. Trotzdem hast du jeden Morgen eine Folge in GZ-Rechnungen bei dir liegen. Jeden Morgen in der Post wollen die ihre 60 Cent sehen. Also es ist auch ein Geldbetteln. Okay. Es ist Budget die Sendung und es entsteht, im Moment entsteht die Sendung. Okay, finde ich cool. Also, wir haben jetzt zwei Ideen, die liegen auf dem Tisch. Wir haben Budget die Sendung und Pizzaturm. Ich hasse Pizzaturm. Wir haben Pizzaturm. Mag ich nicht. Aber es sind ja beides mal Ideen auf dem Tisch. Und ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das ZDF zuhört, aber falls ihr mal irgendwie jungen, aufstrebenden Moderatoren eine Chance geben wollt, dann habt ihr hier zwei Ideen, die wir umsetzen könnten in sieben bis acht Tagen.
Ja?
Ja, warte, warte, das kriegen wir super schnell hin.
Ja, das kriegen wir hin.
Warte, die Show, wir brauchen uns einen Tag.
Wir brauchen nur einen grossen Eimer, wo das Geld reinkommt.
Wir brauchen eine Messehalle mit Publikum. Das ist alles.
Okay.
Das kriegen wir noch hin. Ich war in Napoleon, im Film Napoleon.
Ja.
Und ich bin rausgegangen und habe gedacht, ich muss mit Florian sprechen. Von Hendrik Snyder. Von Ridley Scott. Ridley, ja. Und ich habe sehr viele Fragen an dich. Hast du ihn schon gesehen? Nein, ich habe ihn nicht gesehen. Ich will ihn jetzt, ich bin zur Weihnachtszeit wieder ein bisschen unterwegs in der Heimat, in Minga. Ja, Minga. Minga und da werde ich ihn mir wahrscheinlich reinziehen. Joaquin Phoenix spielt Napoleon. Joaquin Phoenix spielt Napoleon. Ja, sehr sehr schleimig-schlammig wieder. Ist super schleimig-schlammig, genau, es ist ein gritty Film. Ich möchte dir nicht zu viel sagen und sowas, ich habe nur sehr viele Fragen. Wer gewinnt? Genau, ich kann dir auch nicht so viel spoilern, das ist ja das Gute an diesem Film, weil es ja einfach eine Napoleons Geschichte ist. Meine Frage ist aber an dich, a history buff. Weil dann gibt es auch diese Szene vom Wiener Kongress, wo ganz viele Menschen aus ganz verschiedenen Ländern miteinander sprechen. In diesem Film reden alle Englisch, die Franzosen mit einem leicht französischen Akzent, minimal. Markin Phoenix auch? Ein bisschen, aber sehr... Der haut einen Französischen raus? Ohlala, wir müssen angreifen in die Brüche. Weil der war ja gar kein, der hat sehr schlecht Französisch gesprochen. Es war ein Italiener, da seine Muttersprache war Italienisch. Ja, Corse. Ja, Corsacke. Der spricht kein fucking Französisch. Egal. Er hat gar nicht verstanden, was die Leute sagen. Nein. Ah, vive l'Empereur! Und ja, si bene. Si bene, molto bene. Und der spricht halt Englisch wie alle anderen, auch nur, die haben wieder im Kongress, alle sprechen Englisch, so war es ja nicht. Fürstmesser nicht hat Deutsch gesprochen, andere sprechen Französisch, Italienisch, whatever, Englisch. Meine Frage ist, wer hat da übersetzt? Das war ja ein super fucking wichtiges diplomatisches Meeting. Ich glaube, Diplomatie ist in der Übersetzung so heili, heili schwierig, weil du musst ja alle Zwischentöne treffen und kulturelle Unterschiede wissen. Wie spricht man mit den Deutschen, wie spricht man mit den Anzösen und sowas. Wer hat da übersetzt? Ich konnte nichts darüber finden. Also ab wann gab es Übersetzer oder mussten die immer dann die Sprache des anderen lernen? Genau, und dann kennt man auch so aus Biografien von alten Leuten, die irgendwie 18.00 geboren sind oder sowas. Dann sind die mal nach London gereist. Ja und dann, was habt ihr dann da gemacht? Ja. Die sind mit dem Schiff nach London, um da was zu machen. Ja. Wie konntet ihr kommunizieren? Entweder konnte man damals … Also entweder waren die halt super gebildet, weil halt auch nur Leute mit einer Bildung dann irgendwie dahin fahren konnten. Exakt, genau. Oder es gab wirklich so was wie Übersetzer, die man sich mit Groschen dann herbeirufen konnte, die dann übersetzt haben. Translator, Translator. Translator, dann gab es natürlich auch viele Betrüger, die sich dann einfach haben bezahlen lassen, irgendwie so am Hafen, die dann einfach kein Wort gesprochen haben und dann einfach irgendwas erzählt haben. Können Sie, können Sie translaten? Oui, oui, bien sûr, ich kann übersetzen, kein Problem, ich kann übersetzen. Alles klar, auf Englisch, ne, weil genau, okay. Si, si. Ich möchte den Herrn gerne fragen, ob ich vier Fisch kaufen kann. Ja, das ist wieder einer von diesen dummen Främenden, gib ihm einfach irgendeinen alten Fisch und verlangen, viel zu viel geht. Ja. So was. Kann natürlich sein, dass er einfach keine Ahnung hat, was er sagt. Kann schon sein. Das fand ich sehr faszinierend. Und dann andere Frage, warum war der so gut in der Kriegsführung? Alle, ganz Europa wollte ja unter ihm, mit ihm kämpfen, niemand wollte gegen ihn kämpfen. Alle waren begeistert von seiner Kriegsführung. Und dann dachte ich mir, ah geil, ich gehe in den Film, ich will jetzt nicht zu viel verraten. Aber es gibt dann diese erste Szene, die uns zeigen soll, er ist ein guter, krasser Feldherr und er ist sehr gut, was taktische Besonderheiten angeht und sowas und ist einfach sehr gebeefd auf dem Battlefield. Und die Szene ist, er kämpft, die Gegner sagt, ha, easy, sieht da leicht aus, läuft in ihm rein und dann, und da muss ich sich jetzt mal vorstellen, wie clever Bonaparte war, kommen von der Seite auch noch Leute rein. Die waren die ganze Zeit an der Seite. Ja, ja, ja. Stark. Und ich dachte mir, wow, ehrlich? Ja. Das dann hat ein bisschen, er war der, er war der, der das erfunden hat. Er war der von der Seite, oh nö, von der Seite, er hat die Flanke erfunden. Ja, aber Leute. Quasi, was heute in der Bundesliga Alltag ist, schön die Flanke rein. Ich dachte mir, das kann doch nicht. Ernsthaft.
Es ist super schwer, sowas darzustellen. Ich denke mir das auch immer so, was ist es letzten Endes? Es ist super schwer und natürlich, was ich auch immer gerne mag in so Filmen, in so Biopics, ist, wie dann so erzählt wird, warum das so ist. Und oft gibt's dann diese Szene in der Kindheit, wo er dann irgendwie so von allen Kindern gemobbt wird oder so im Sandkasten und dann baut er irgendwie so eine Falle oder eine Grube, weil er sich irgendwie gegen die Übermacht wehren muss und man denkt, ah, deswegen ist der so gut, deswegen hat er das. Ja, diese Verkürzungen in Bio-Kricks. So dieser Quatsch einfach, was einfach Nonsens ist oder warum er das so machen muss. Weil Leben nicht dramaturgisch sind und nicht unbedingt immer eine Erklärung in der Kindheit haben. Ja. Dann will man es es aber verkürzen, weil man halt natürlich irgendwie diese, ja diese Tropen, die man kennt aus Filmen, die kein Biopic sind, Biopic. Es ist super schwierig. Ich finde für mich noch die nachvollziehbarste Schlacht der Menschheitsgeschichte ist Troja. Das war, da checkt man, ah okay, riesiges Holzpferd, rein, macht das Tor auf, die gehen nachts rein und der Gegner rechnet damit nicht, weil er nicht dachte, dass in einem riesigen Holzpferd Menschen drin sind. Weil normalerweise sind Menschen auf einem Pferd und die Griechen hatten aber die Idee, nee, nicht auf dem Pferd, in dem Pferd, innen drin. Das finde ich so stark. Und da checkt jeder, das ist eine geile Idee. Geile Idee. Das ist eine geile Idee. Wenn ich so eine Szene gesehen hätte, habe ich gedacht, okay, ich verstehe, warum alle mit ihm kämpfen wollen. Ja. Also mit ihm, zusammen. Ja, genau. Was war eigentlich der zweite Hit, von welchem immer griechischen General die Idee hatte, was war die zweite Idee? Also gibt es da noch ein zweites Album? So, die nächsten für den Pitch Troja 2. Hier Florian und Stefan. Hi, ja, genau. Also, was willst du? Soll ich? Also, weil Troja war ja schon ein erfolgreicher Film, Oliver Stone und so. Erstmal vielen Dank für, ah ne, ich dachte, ja. Also vielen Dank. Unsere Idee wäre, dass für den zweiten Pitch, also sozusagen für zweite Troja, dachten wir ein grosses Kamel. Genau. Weil da passen mehr Menschen rein. In die Höcker. Zwei Höcker. Und wir haben auch noch ein bisschen zu trinken dabei. Wir dachten, in den Höckern ist dann noch so einmal Wasser. Genau. Dann können die nämlich länger drinbleiben. Weil natürlich würde Troja beim zweiten Mal vermuten, ah, da sind wieder Soldaten drin und würde dann irgendwie das Kamel bewachen und dann warten, bis die rauskommen. Aber dieses Mal können die länger drinbleiben und ausharren, weil Wasser in den Höckern drin ist. Und das waren wir von Trojanisches Kamel. Wir haben auch hier einen kleinen Imagefilm vorbereitet. Troja. Eine Schlacht, die es so schnell nicht noch mal gab. Eine geniale Idee, Menschen in einem grossen Tier. Das Ganze passiert noch mal mit trojanischem Kamel. Stockfoodisch, ganz viel Stockfoodisch auch zu sehen. Wir sind nicht nur in dem Körper, sondern immer noch mehr Leute passen oben rein, in die Höcker, geschnitten vom Capcut. Also okay, nochmal genau das gleiche, was ihr gesagt habt. Ja, das ist natürlich eine gute Idee. Ja, erstmal vielen Dank. Also ich finde, ich gucke gerade übrigens die ganze Zeit Shark Tank. Ich bin so in einem fucking Shark Tank Modus drin. Ich habe neulich geweint, mehrere Male bei Shark Tank.
Moment, aber du hast, also das heisst, du hast geweint, dann hast du aufgehört zu weinen und dann hast du neu angefangen zu weinen oder war es ein längeres Weinen am Stück? Verschiedene Momente bei Shark Tank bringen mich gerade zum Weinen. Ich weiss nicht, ob es diese Zeit ist gerade gerade zwischen den Jahren, um Weihnachten rum, man ist irgendwie emotional oder sowas oder empathisch veranlagt. Lass uns nur kurz ein paar Vokabeln klären. Im Deutschen ist es die Höhle der Löwen. Und im Englischen ist es Shark Tank. Im Englischen ist es Dragon's Den. Dragon's Den. Also die Deutschen sind die einzigen, die sich für den Reim entschieden haben. Höhle der Löwen? Na bitte, besser als Shark Tank. Höhle der Löwen, das ist ein halber Reim. Ich mag Höhle der Löwen sehr. Höhle der Löwen, das klingt. Wohingegen Dragon's Den, da ist ja nix, das ist eine gute Alliteration von mir aus. Dragon's Den ist das Original, ich weiss nicht, ob das Original sogar aus Japan oder sowas kommt. Die englische Version heißt jedenfalls Dragon's Den, deutsche Höhle der Löwen, amerikanisches Shark Tank. Ja. Du mal, Lebenhöhlen, Lebenlöwen in Höhlen. Nebenhöhlen. Lebenhöhlen in Nebenhöhlen, ist meine Frage. Leben Löwen in Nebenhöhlen. Ein paar Löwen leben in Sicherheit in Nebenhöhlen, ja. Okay. Lebenlöwen in Höhlen, ich glaube, weiss ich nicht genau. Also so wie ich es kenne, in der Savanne unter Bäumen. Aber es ist allgemein eine gefährliche Situation. Was? Da sind wir uns einig. Also ich will weder in der Höhle der Löwen noch in der Shark Tank. Noch in der Dragon's Den noch in der Schlangengrube. Shark Tank verstehe ich auch nicht. Aquarium, also die meinen so ein Sea Life Center mit Aquar... Da zeigt sich, dass wir, was Wassergebiete angeht, keine vernünftigen Wörter haben. Wir könnten sowas wie Cove sagen oder sowas oder Bay, Sharks Bay. Aber das klingt nicht so bedrohlich wie die Höhle der Löwen, da ist man eingesperrt. Wohingegen beim Shark, da müsste man eine Grotte vielleicht, the Grotto of the Sharks oder so müsste man sagen. Shark Riff. Shark Riff, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Aber es ist nicht gefährlich genug, da denkst du ja beim Riff, man kann ja einfach wegschwimmen. Ich finde Shark Tank aber geil. Shark Tank ist okay. Die Musik ist brillant. Mein Problem ist nur im Englischen gibt es ja to shoot fish in a barrel. Etwas sehr leichtes ist, Fische in einem Fass zu schiessen. Aber du bist ja das Opfer. Es ist sehr schwer zu entkommen in einem Shark Tank. Genau, aber für mich ist dieses Bild Fische in einem eingeschlossenen Gefäss immer ein Zeichen von Zahm. Das ist nicht schlimm, das ist nicht schwer. Weil geh halt nicht rein. Aber das ist ja auch die Idee vom Shark Tank. Du absichtlich gehst so in den Tank. Geh halt nicht rein, kann man ja auch auf die Hülle der Löwen sagen. Okay, wenn ich wusstest, ja, okay.
Ja, generell.
Aber es ist eine Art, was Domestiziertes.
Aber es sind immer noch fucking Sharks.
Es sind immer noch Haie.
Okay, und du heilst dir die Augen aus.
Ich heu dir die Augen aus, wenn dann jemand irgendwie den Zuschlag bekommt und vorher von seiner krebskranken Mutter erzählt und dann kriegt er da den Zuschlag.
Und du hast dann diese highly capitalist Geist.
Ich meine, du hast ja Mark Cuban sitzen, Besitzer der Miami Heats oder was auch immer, Dallas Mavericks, glaube ich, aber dann hast du da, das war wirklich so krass schwer kapitalistische, sehr, sehr super reiche, krasse Motherfucker sitzen, das ist noch mal krasser als im Deutschen. Ja, ja. Und die sind halt so milliardär, milliardenschwer.
Und das ist noch mal krasser als im Deutschen. Und die sind halt milliardenschwer und das ist schon krass, wie die halt dann grössere Summen mal eben aus den Ärmel leiern, aber auch viel krassere, halsabschleiderische Deals machen mit irgendwelchen Royalties, bis in alle Ewigkeit und sowas. Aber ja, es ist ganz krass und ich finde das so eine fantastische Sendung. Ich kann mich da stundenlang auseinandersetzen. Ich finde es auch geil, wie dann diese sehr cleveren, arguably sehr cleveren Menschen reden über diese Ideen. Die haben ja zu allem eine Meinung, zu allem eine starke Meinung, da konnte jemand rein mit fucking Peanut Butter Pumpen. Also so eine Pumpe, die machst du auf das Peanut Butter Glas und dann kannst du die raus und dann ist da oben so ein Aufsatz, dass du es direkt aufs Brot schmieren kannst. Ja, hi Leute, ich bin Florentin, ich will euch heute mein Produkt vorstellen. Genau, wir sind Florentin und Stefan und wir suchen 10% für 100.000 Euro, also 10% Anteil unserer Firma. Also Klimawandel, es wird immer heisser. Die Menschen müssen irgendwie damit klarkommen, dass es immer heisser wird. Und was macht man, wenn man, wenn es heiss ist? Man schwitzt. Und deswegen haben wir gesagt, die Cap mit dem eingebauten Stirnwischer. Es ist wie ein Scheibenwischer, nur er wischt die Stirn. Du setzt das Cap auf und genau wie ein Scheibenwischer, der weiss, wann es feucht ist, wischt er dir die Stirn ab. Wir haben einen Prototyp hier mal gebaut. Stefan hat den gebaut, er hat einen 3D-Drucker und wir haben das mal gebaut und wir wollen euch mal vorführen, wie das funktioniert. Hier, hier, Schaks, bitte. Hier, jeder kriegt einen. Hier Mr O'Leary, hier Mr Cuban. So, also es ist ein ganz normaler Cap erstmal, die setzt man auf. Und dann ist es jetzt hier ein bisschen heiss, auch mit den Scheinwerfern, ich bin ein bisschen nervös, ich schwitze jetzt. Pull den Schwitzchen, Schwein. Und jetzt... Ah, au, au, au, au! Okay, okay, das war... Also das ist dann die Idee, also der würde dann sozusagen einfach den Schweiss abwischen. Okay, Jungs, also erstmal sehr sehr beeindruckende Idee, also das Problem, das uns alle beschäftigt, klar. Was ist euer Hintergrund, also wo kommt ihr beide her, was ist euer Hintergrund? Wir haben uns auf der Uni kennengelernt, wir wollten beide Produktdesign studieren und haben dann beide die abgebrochen und haben uns dann sozusagen auf der Fahrt nach Hause kennengelernt, lustigerweise. Wie ist die Idee entstanden? Die Idee ist entstanden, wir schwitzen beide sehr, sehr viel und wir sind im Bus gefahren
und da hat es geregnet und dann haben wir gesehen einen Scheibenwischer beim Bus und
dann habe ich an meine krebskranke Oma gedacht, weil die auch immer...
Da kommt diese Musik.
Und dann...
Als wir reinkamen, kam übrigens diese den den den den den den den den den den den den den den hi hi und dann haben wir unsere idee vorgestellt das war am anfang okay und da haben wir den scheibenwischer gesehen und dachten wir einfach okay schwitzen scheibenwischer warum kann man nicht andere flüssigkeiten automatisiert wegwischen lassen? Super, ihr sucht 10% für 100.000, heisst ihr bewertet euer Unternehmen mit einer Million Dollar. Wie genau kommt auf diese Zahlen? Führt euch ein bisschen durch die letzten Jahre mit den Sales. Ja, also wir haben verkauft zwei an meine krebskranke Oma. Okay, da sind jetzt kaum Sales, also irgendwie hätte da was passiert. Das Problem ist, dass wir leider das nicht so gut an die Kopfform anpassen können, wodurch manchmal einfach das nicht so gut funktioniert. Wir haben jetzt zwei verkauft, an meine krebskranke Oma und an meine krebskranke Tante. Und also den beiden hat das sehr gut gefallen. Okay, weil ihr eine Million Euro sucht, deswegen. Wie kommt ihr auf diesen Firmenwert? Es kostet 100 Euro pro Kappe. 100 Euro pro Kappe? Das sind coole Caps. Was kostet euch das, die zu machen? Das kostet uns ungefähr so 80 Euro.
80 Euro, die zu machen?
100 Euro. Es ist eine coole stylische Cap, die man auch so einfach tragen kann, aber die Technik darin ist komplett solarbetrieben. Das heisst, der Akku lädt sich selber auf. Der wird manchmal ein bisschen heiß, aber wie gesagt, wenn man schwitzt, wird es hier weggesmischt. Okay, also ich muss sagen, eure Sales stimmen nicht, Ihr könnt die Caps nicht in die Kopfform anpassen. Die kostet 100 Euro, 80 zu machen. Die Marge ist super gering, es brennt die Kopfhaut weg und du hast keine Stirn mehr. Und aus diesen Gründen bin ich leider raus. Okay. So sieht das dann so nicht aus. Und dann so ein Zoom auf unser Gesicht, ganz gross. Und Stefan hat die ganze Zeit nichts gesagt. Nichts gesagt. Stand daneben, mit diesen Prototypen, zitternd stand ich daneben. Den Schmerz versteckend. Ich finde es fantastisch. Also kann ich nur empfehlen. Man kann es so wegsnacken. Und da gibt es mehrere Staffeln und dann... Bei YouTube kann man einfach Clips gucken. Die geilen Clips. Ich habe das nur manchmal gesehen, irgendwann mal im Kühlregal diesen Keksteig zum Löffeln. Und da stand gross draus, bekannt aus Höhle der Löwen. Genau. Wo ich mir immer denke, ist das eine gute Art der Werbung, zu schreiben, das ist aus Höhle der Löwen. Weil für mich ist das kein Produkt, das sich organisch durchgesetzt hat, sondern das ist in der Fernsehsendung halt genommen worden, weil zwei Leute dachten, das ist eine witzige Idee. Ich denke mir immer so, das ist so ein bisschen, nee, du hast es nicht von dir aus geschafft. Das ist so ein bisschen wie so ein E-Bike. Weil, ich meine, ich bin Fahrradfahrer, wissen wir alle, und früher war, sag ich mal, der Wilde Westen klar. Wer schnell fahren kann, fährt schnell. Wenn jemand an dir vorbeizieht, dann bist du ein krasser Fahrradfahrer. Und du hast dich untergeordnet, du hast dich auf den Rücken gelegt, du warst besiegt. Aber mittlerweile zieht halt auch irgendwie die Oma an dir vorbei. Du kommst nicht hinterher und du denkst dir, ist das ein E-Bike oder nicht? Und du hast keinen Referenzrahmen mehr. Und so ist es, finde ich, auch wenn du so ein bisschen diese Vetternwirtschaft von dieser Höhle der Löwen, weisst du nicht, hat der das aus eigenem Antrieb geschafft oder hat der so diesen Boost bekommen von dieser Firma? Der ist gerade nur hier im Rewe, weil der Rewe-Guy sitzt auch bei Höhle der Löwen und der verhält das für eine gute Idee, der jetzt gekauft. Andererseits wäre es auch hier im Supermarkt, wenn er das organisch gepitcht hätte. Weil, ich, komm, wir kommen ja selber auch aus dem Fernsehen, wir wissen ja so ein bisschen, wie so eine Sendung läuft.
Natürlich denken die sich, wir können nicht jedes Produkt ablehnen.
Ja, und in Deutschland ist so viel Scheisse.
Ja.
Im Amerikanischen war Spikeball dabei, was alle in den Parks spielen, was du auch schon mal gesehen hast, wo die sind runden Trampolinsding. Spikeball war bei Shark Tank.
Ach cool.
Du kennst halt einfach fucking Firmen, die bei Shark Tank, die Ringkamera, die überall jetzt gerade gibt, die von Amazon gekauft wurde, wurde bei Shark Tank nicht genommen. Und das ist so lustig zu gucken dieses Video, wie alle diese Ringkamera nicht verstehen. Und der Typ war mega smart schon, richtig clever, hat auch alle Angebote, glaube ich, Angebot sogar abgelehnt und dann wurde seine Firma für eine Milliarde von Amazon gekauft und es ist einer der erfolgreichen Firmen der Welt, die Ringkamera, weil alle die jetzt hinhängen, das finde ich zum Beispiel geil. Und das hast du in Deutschland halt nicht, da hast du recht, da kommen halt drei Unternehmen an, die sind alle lustig, aber ein bisschen peinlich, du kannst nicht dreimal absagen, du musst eine nehmen. Du kannst nicht eine komplette Sendung machen aus, nee, machen wir nicht, ist eine saudumme Idee, machen wir nicht. Du hast ja wahrscheinlich eine gewisse Quote und musst irgendwas annehmen, ob die gut sind oder nicht. Vor allem, du musst ja, angenommen, die Sendung ist neu, du weißt nicht, wer kommt. Ja. So, dann sagst du das erst, kommt jemand rein und stellt unsere Kappen, die die Stirn wegschmieren, vor. Dann sagst du, hell no, nein, nein. Dann kommt jemand rein und sagt hier einen Schrank. Ja, okay, es gibt Schränke. Ja, aber man kann in dem Schrank schlafen. Ja. Also man kann auch rein schlafen. Auf gar keinen Fall. Dann kommt der dritte rein und sagt, man kann, ich, einen Schuhschrank, man kann auch drin schlafen und man sagt, was ist hier los? Man guckt zu den Redakteuren und denkt, was passiert hier gerade? Kommen die Fette rein und bringen die Jucca-Palme mit. Ich verkaufe Jucca-Palme im grossen Stil, ich kann sie ein bisschen günstiger einkaufen als mit Konkurrenz. Man denkt, okay, das Beste von allem, ich investiere rein, weil, was soll hier noch passieren? Genau, mein Geld muss irgendwo hin. Weil wenn diese Sendung mal ja irgendwann mal neu. Jaja,, klar. Und man sagt, die funktioniert nicht, die Sendung, weil es kamen nur Nieten.
Ab welchem Moment sagt man nein? Und dann gibt es dieses berühmte mathematische Beispiel, wie viele Leute muss man sehen, um zu wissen, wie der Durchschnitt aussieht. Also angenommen, das heisst Sekretärinnenbeispiel, ich war super alt und deswegen so ein bisschen Show-Wie-mäßig betitelt, aber wenn man hundert Leute sind, potenzielle Bewerber auf den Job. Du kannst beim ersten noch nicht sagen, ob der jetzt gut oder schlecht war. Kann schon der beste gewesen sein, weiss man nicht. Zweite hörst du dir an, denkst du, hm, und mathematisch berechnet macht es Sinn, ab dem siebenunddreissigsten zu entscheiden. Also du musst dir bei 100 Leuten kommen, musst du 37 Leute dir anhören, und ab dem 37. kannst du entscheiden, wenn jemand besser ist als der, als jemand aus dem ersten Block bis 37, dann würdest du ihn am besten nehmen. Mathematisch die sicherste Entscheidung, um den besten Wert zu finden. Gott, das wäre in 37. Crazy, ne? 37. Also, wenn ihr ihn bewerbt, seht zu, dass ihr Nummer 37 oder upwards seid. Okay. Das ist ein kleiner Tipp fürs neue Jahr. Fürs neue Jahr, falls ihr vorhabt, Bewerber zu sein oder irgendwelche Bewerber mal zu interviewen, 37 ist die Zahl für euch. Genau, ansonsten vielen Dank an Nummermer zwei florentin und um einst ja habt eine schöne woche vielen dank und startet schön ins neue jahr
und mit uns ein ja wir freuen uns auf ein neuer jahr mal zauber und the whole year has been the worst bird production.